what's up guys mkbhd here welcome back
to quarantine content just a little
entertainment for you while we're all
staying inside
I'm your host marques Brownlee and this
is our first look at a new phone one of
the shiniest as you can tell this is the
Huawei P 40 Pro now it's hard to think
about Huawei phones without reminding
ourselves you know no frequent Google
Play services updates no Android updates
so no matter how good this phone is it's
still not likely to be a phone that
people like me in this market are going
to buy import or even recommend to
others but that being said it is still
really cool to see a new high-end phone
in 2020 the squall weighs showed really
cool stuff in the past so the lens
through which I'm looking at this phone
is what stuff from this phone should
other manufacturers copy so that those
features end up in more hands around the
world that's how I'm looking at this
phone so okay first thing to look at
with a new phone is the design and this
design is one of my favorite things
about it now a lot of it is pretty
standard for a high-end flagship right
now and I'm not talking about that you
know we've all seen the rounded square
look and the huge camera bump which I'll
get to in a second and the metal rails
on the side the speaker at the bottom
with no headphone jack we've all seen
that before but this material though
it's not even the ceramic back of the
Pro Plus it's just it's got this super
soft touch finish on the glass that just
feels silky smooth I don't know if the
word satin is in this color name but
it's pretty great Plus this lighter gray
color doesn't show many fingerprints at
all and it even refracts light pretty
softly so it's not a mirror and it's
easy to record this is one of my
favorite phone back finishes ever no
offence dbrand this is not a phone that
should be skinned this should go naked
people should feel the back or maybe a
clear back case or something like that
but yeah this this I hope gets copied
and then you've got the screen up front
and this one is a mixed bag so it's a
six point five eight inch OLED display
so not to mass
and it's twenty six forty by twelve
hundred at ninety Hertz
not quite the highest end but viewing
angles and and brightness and colors are
all high-end and they're nice to look at
but what's much more interesting about
this screen is the shape so this display
not only curves over the edges of the
left and right side but it also kind of
has a bit of this overflow shape on the
top and bottom edges too so always said
their goal with this display shape was
to make the whole thing look like it's
this overflowing screen like the surface
of water overflowing from the top of a
glass with surface tension and the promo
material you've probably seen in this
phone has it looking like pretty much
all screen but what we've ended up with
is this and it's a good-looking screen
but it mostly just seems like
everything's rounded off and of course
the corners don't really get to curve in
like that so you end up with this very
unique shape that's not necessarily
better it's like if you imagine trying
to wrap a circular gift with wrapping
paper and you try to wrap over the
entire sphere without creasing anything
like you're gonna end up with some
creases in that screen at some point so
it's not the worst thing in the world
but you can see it is still mostly
screen but this isn't something I
necessarily copy also you've definitely
noticed that huge cut out by now
it's for this selfie camera and a depth
sensor and infrared this is about as
small as you can get actually a pill
shaped cutout if you want to still have
all three of those things but I think
we're finding more and more that the
extra depth sensors are not necessarily
as useful as we've thought they are but
the infrared in the middle is nice to
have for face unlock in low-light
environments when I see this I think of
the iPhone and its massive notch because
of course they have all those face ID
sensors and I'm hoping maybe finally
this year we see a much smaller notch in
the new iPhone they seem pretty
committed to face ID and keeping the
infrared and all that stuff at the top
but if we're seeing that while we can do
this pill shape cut out being much
smaller than a notch then hopefully
Apple can shrink the notch this year too
then underneath this display is the new
optical fingerprint reader which they
say is 30% larger
30% faster when I heard that I was like
oh thank you sweet on paper those
improvements are great I've been saying
we should get these fingerprint readers
like the whole bottom half of the screen
so it's just easy you don't even have to
think about it but in practice actually
using this one I can't even really tell
if it's actually bigger in fact the
animation which you can see where it
lights up is about the same size as last
year and it's fast which is great but
really getting that sensor larger is the
technical challenge here plus I think
this one's actually a little higher up
on the phone than I would have wanted
but I will still say I hope other
manufacturers copy continuing to work on
making fitting bigger sensors in these
screens so then really probably the
biggest focus of this new phone is the
camera system on the back what I know
it's so subtle did you even notice it
back there the p40 Pro has a quad camera
system so 50 megapixel main camera with
oh is with an absolutely massive one
over 1.2 inch sensor then a 40 megapixel
ultra wide camera and a 12 megapixel 5x
optical periscope camera you can see
over there on the side with that
recognizable rectangle all on the back
with the time-of-flight sensor and a mic
and the flash as well interestingly if
the galaxy s 20 Ultra didn't exist I
think it would be easy to look at this
camera and the numbers and think oh wow
it looks like while was just playing the
numbers game with their camera they're
trying to throw as many of the biggest
numbers as possible at us to hopefully
equal a good camera but Huawei's angle
is actually almost the exact opposite of
that they said basically we don't think
we need to go all out with the numbers
we're not hitting a hundred here but we
do want to strike a balance between high
numbers and actually good performance
okay
please copy that but of course you can
only copy the approach of the camera as
far as getting to actual execution now
this camera as far as it translates it's
still early I've only had this phone for
two days for my first impressions but it
seems pretty good usually really good
I've taken a lot of good photos a lot of
sharp photos with this camera
it is binning and spitting out 12
megapixel photos by default and for the
most part both
standard and the ultra-wide are giving
me pretty consistent photos although the
ultra-wide is still a little bit softer
despite it's 40 megapixels but you're
also going to notice from the main
camera that huge huge sensor has some of
the same problems as the huge sensor
from the s20 ultra basically with the
plane of focus being so thin that close
up subjects aren't completely in focus
and you do start to get some fringing no
autofocus problems though that phase
attack autofocus in this phone seems
rock-solid despite the problems the s20
ultra had but yeah overall here if you
look past the numbers this is a solid
camera that reminds me of many Huawei
cameras in the past as far as color and
high exposure and just a general shot
style matter of fact if any of the
cameras here impressed me it was
actually the selfie camera with all the
beauty modes turned off because it kept
a ton of detail that to me is a really
good first impression the battery in
this phone is 4200 milliamp hours and if
anything it feels like a bigger battery
trend is sort of a way of everyone's
hopping on now everyone copying that is
a good thing but this one takes it a
step further p40 pro has 40 watt wired
charging and incredibly support for 40
watt fast wireless charging which is
awesome for context the thousand dollar
iPhone 11 pro max ships with an 18 watt
wired fast charger I don't even know if
I have access to a wireless charger that
cranks out 40 watts of power but the
second I can I will try to get my hands
on it but until then other manufacturers
yes please copy that and then the rest
of the specs of this phone are pretty
high-end if you're wondering not
bleeding edge but the Karen 998 gigs of
ram 128 or 256 gigs of storage ip68
water-resistant 5g enabled and there are
a bunch of other little things it does
well there's software mui 10.1 while it
is better with every iteration it's
still nowhere near being able to
recommend for this market yes they do
have Huawei zap gallery and a lot of
other familiar features and UI tweaks
like oh I don't know swiping down from
the home screen to bring up a search box
and app suggestions and a stock weather
app that
it's not just eerily close but pretty
obviously close to another certain
weather app and even a new voice
assistant they're launching called Celia
Celia and you can trigger it by saying
hey Celia which I don't want to say
they're copying anyone but if you say it
fast enough hey Celia so you know I
think what you wish but really the
software if it was anything amazing or
game-changing here that would be the
easiest to tell other manufacturers to
copy because they copy software all the
time
seems like while was just already ahead
of the game in that department so
overall my take is p40 Pro is a nice
package and it wouldn't be a bad upgrade
for pretty much anyone with a two or
three-year-old phone and while it is
missing a couple of the absolute highest
end bleeding-edge stuff like a que video
or a hundred twenty Hertz there is a lot
of good stuff in here for the rest of
the industry to pick up on and that's a
win for all of us
alright so to end it big shout out to
this video sponsor Nord VPN this one is
specifically to help you expand your
quarantine content library because the
VPN can let you see websites as if
you're visiting from another country or
a different region so a lot of people
don't know there's a different version
of YouTube for the US and YouTube for UK
and YouTube for India so pro tip
changing your region or your country
with the VPN will not only unlock a
whole bunch of YouTube videos that were
previously blocked in your country but
will also basically unearth entire new
libraries like this is literally true
for Netflix so I didn't realize Doctor
Who is only available on Netflix UK but
now that you know about Nord VPN you can
watch it from anywhere you're welcome
plus all the other privacy and security
benefits of a VPN that you've probably
already heard me talk about so if you
want 70% off plus one additional month
free and why wouldn't you you can use
promo code mkbhd and get started with
Nord VPN today so thanks again for an
order VPN for sponsoring this video good
luck with the rest of your hashtag
quarantine content catch you guys in the
next one peace